hello and um good afternoon and uh good
evening to uh
everyone here and um thank you for
joining me in my presentation today so
i will be
uh talking about
um what we've been doing here at the
university of chicago um in the field of
pharmacogenomics
so in my presentation
um i'll be uh going through
what is pharmacogenomics kind of a brief
history of why is it important
why we need to do this and
some of the technology that has been
used um in pharmacogenomics in the past
five or six years or so and what we're
currently using
and where the future is heading
so just a very brief introduction um in
uh every year there's um at least uh two
million average drug reactions that
occur
and all these um greater than two
million average drug reactions um
it leads to approximately a hundred
thousand dollars
uh when we look at the cost of drug
related mobility morbidity and mortality
it's estimated to be at least 76 billion
dollars
in addition to that um of the new drugs
that are being put in the market right
now about four percent of these new
drugs are withdrawn due to average drug
reactions um just from uh 1995 to 2005
um 34 drugs have been withdrawn mainly
due to uh the paddle and cardio toxin
effects on the patient
and um and
we are uh
fairly aware of this now that not all
drugs work for all patients and
um
estimation is about 25 to 60 percent of
uh patients are effective for children's
lungs now the question is why
um
does this happen and um
this can occur for a variety of
different reasons and it can range from
anywhere from patient to non-compliance
not taking your drugs or the other
spectrum is that
the genetic makeup of a person makes uh
certain patients more prone to
average drug reactions for certain drugs
and uh when we talk about the
genetically developed person
is that for different drugs
many proteins and enzymes are involved
with the
metabolism of the drugs um and also the
elimination of the
uh from the body so any uh genetic
variation that affects the activity of
these proteins are involved in these
processes can
make a person a patient previous phone
to
the effectiveness of certain drugs
so in this slide right here it just kind
of gives you an overall um idea of how
effective certain drugs are and you can
see that even for um
uh well-established drugs like uh
statins for cholesterol you know it's
only effective for thirty to seventy
percent uh of the patients that their
smartphones so again i just wanted to
reiterate at this point that
um these figures here um you have to
factor in that part of it is due to
patient non-compliance um not taking it
too long properly or taking at the right
time but um also that the genetic makeup
of the patient also play a major factor
in this
so with pharmacogenomics when we look at
the um the genotype and the genes of the
patient what are we trying to get here
um or what does it promise so
what we're hoping from pharmacogenomics
is that we can prescribe the right drug
for the right patient at the right bills
of the time so we call these the four
horrors
um and with uh accomplishing the four
arcs what we can hope is that we can
maximize the drug efficacy for these
patients
decrease abnormal struggle relations
and on top of that big pharma actually
has started to take a big interest in
this because
um what they have seen is that they can
actually salvage some of the drugs that
have been previously failed
and we know that um it takes cost a lot
of
money and resources for pharma to
develop drugs and on this slide here
there has been three drugs that have
been previously um withdrawn
um for various reasons but because of
pharmacogenomics they have received
a second chance so that these drugs can
maybe be uh very effective for a subset
of um
of patients and uh
the candidate for targeted therapy
when we look at the um the overall view
of what happens when a patient takes
some drugs there are several different
things that we have to keep in mind so
first of all we can start off with a
drug deal so this is the amount of job
that patient takes and uh when we when
the patient takes the drug then um we
think about what is the biological fuel
concentration of the drug so for example
this will be the drug that
you can measure in the blood samples
then the next step after that is the
effective site concentration so this is
um when a drug is targeted against a
specific protein or specific cell type
what is the effective concentration of
that glove at that site
and then at the very end uh then we can
see the pharmacological effect
so in the in the field of
pharmacogenomics um
there are basically four steps that can
control and affect all of these
different steps so the first one is
absorption of the drug
the second is the distribution of the
drug
third is the metabolism of the drug and
the fourth is the inspiration of the
blood so the acne cortisone
as i previously needed to um the
proteins are involved in each step of
those uh
each of those four steps
and uh genetic variation in each one of
the patients can affect them and what
kind of genetic variation are we talking
about here uh the most common ones that
we are looking at are what we call
single nucleotide polymorphisms
um these are
single uh
nucleotide changes within the genetic
within the genome of a person
and um
and these can affect um the
protein or the enzyme that is that the
dna codes for
so just some quick facts about um single
nuclear polymorphisms first of all
they're not homogeneously distributed
throughout the genome so they tend to be
clustered in certain areas in the gene
um they usually occur in non-coding
regions so regions in the dna that does
not proclaim protein
uh more frequently than the regions that
do quote for protein
and as of 2011 um
the uh ncbi database for a single
nucleotide polymorphism have catalogued
about 52 million different uh snips
in the human genome
so what can we use the single nucleotide
polymorphisms for what they've been
using dna fingerprinting
um studies have also shown that uh snips
have been uh the underlying difference
in
uh different patients susceptibility and
protection from different kinds of
diseases and also um
in the field of pharmacogenomics it
affects the
severe the severity of illnesses and the
way that our volumes respond to certain
treatments
um something that uh that i will um
allude to later on in the in the
presentation is what we call haplotype
and uh what a haplotype is is um a group
of snips that tend to be inherited uh
from generation to generation together
oh um i forgot to mention uh this
previously but um
uh if there's any questions or uh
anything please wait till the end of the
presentation and i will answer them
there
ah so continue on with the presentation
here so in the field of pharmacogenomic
system terminology here so there are
mainly four different terminology here
depending on the severity of the loss of
function
so
a poor metabolizer means that there's no
functionality meaning that in any one
patient there are two alleles and one
for mom and one from uh
dad and both of them are non-functional
so this is indicate in a way kind of
like a worst case scenario where
you have very uh almost where you
basically have no enzymatic activity
the next one is intermediate
metabolizing where of the two uh alleles
only one is functioning so
in
this case right here um the patients
tend to have a
lower enzyme activity
uh what we call wild type where there's
two functionalities is an extensive
metabolizer and when a person actually
has a duplication event where there's
actually more than two functional
alleles these with patients what are
called also wrapping metabolisms so
these patients tend to have very high
enzyme activity
so that kind of gives us a background of
what pharmacogenomics and um
what it can be used for
now um for the past five or six years um
there has been many different types of
technologies that can be used in uh
looking at the genotyping uh for
assignment genomics um by far the most
common way um
for the past five six years are dna and
race-based
systems there are some real-time
pcr-based systems out there and
more recently i say within the last year
or so we're starting to see more and
more adoption of dna sequencing in
bondage
so this slide right here uh kind of
shows um some of the fda clear um
tests for pharmacogenomics um all of
these here are either um dna array-based
technology or real-time pcr
and so you can see that there are a
variety of different um
platforms out there for different types
of tests
and the target drug is also listed there
so you have uh
panels that will be uh geared towards
warframe also a nano t-can and there's
some other more
generic uh panels out there that are not
necessarily uh specific for any type of
example
so um some of the more common um
uh dna array-based uh technologies out
there is based off of um
uh the ability of pcr the uh
ability of the pcr able to amplify
certain primers so in this case what you
will have is that you'll have a two
different partners one that will bind to
the wild type sequence and then another
primary that will bind to a
mutant or a
polymorphism
and then depending on which primary is
well um you can the pcr reaction can
happen and it will generate different
flows and signals
so when you put this um on the system
you're basically
looking at different fluorescent signals
one represents one signal representing
the wild type and in the other
representing a certain polynomial
the advantages of uh using these dna and
rate-based systems is that um they are
highly automated and they require very
little hands-on time as demonstrated by
the auto genomics infiniti platform here
so you can see that there are several
different steps are required and each
one of them requires less than five
minutes or so
of a hands-on
so from the very beginning to the very
end we can get from
the from starting from dna to results it
takes about five hours so
it's um the testing um using the dna
varies and not uh do not take that
um the real-time pcr base um strategies
uses um
probes that have a
fluorescent quencher and also a
thoroughfare so um um
when you add this the purple bind to the
uh the region of excess
and at that time there would be no false
signal
uh so what will happen is that when uh
uh the pcr um if the probe is able to
buy
um the pcr reaction will occur and it
will start displacing the probe and what
happens is that your probe as it's being
displaced will get chewed up and then
the quencher will then flow away from
your forehead
and the result is that he will start
begin to detect the signal
so that's how basically a real-time pcr
strategy works so in this case your
quotes are designed to apply to either
the wild type or a specific that's in
the paper
at the university of chicago we decided
initially to implement
a um array-based platform and we were
using the um genmark system um the
advantage of the genmark system is that
it's really fast
from the beginning to the end it takes
about four hours so
uh that and that includes um dna
extraction so this slide here just kind
of highlights the the key steps are
involved here so you start off with a
two behold the audio isolate the dna one
and then uh in step two there is a pcr
reaction that will amplify the
region of interest and then there's also
actual nucleus um a reaction there that
will remove and convert your pcr
amplifies to single-stranded dna
you take this mixture and then you add
it on its chip and then you put it on
the machine
how this um array works is that it's
based on the hybridization of your
amplifiers so in this line here it shows
that
um there is a capture point that will
hybridize the part of your uh
application
and then you will have two different
proteins one that one problem will bind
to a wall wall-type
polymorphism and then the other will
apply to the polymorphism and both will
have a different um
force and label so it is an
electrochemical reaction when the probe
is able to buy and the forcing label
comes in contact with the data electrode
so this is the type of signal that we
would typically get
so if you have a wall type then you'll
see basically the green peak
representing the wild type pro
if you have a homozygous mutant then you
see the red peak representing uh the
whole um the just like
your mutant binding and when you have a
heterozygous we actually get a double p
uh one for representing one one
representing the wild type and then the
other representing
so
um we went through and we started to
validate
the dna array platform uh but when we
start looking at uh um assessing the
different platforms of it there are some
limitations for dna arrays um
first and this slide kind of highlights
uh some of these uh
limitations so first of all in all of
these um
uh platforms out there the wow type is
assumed so what i mean by that is that
if they see no signal uh from uh on the
chip that means that they assume that
it's valentine
um
and
different companies using different uh
polymorphisms to call the genotype so if
you look at um
for example
the star 2
um mutation here when you look at the
luminex uh platform they use four
different um snips to call that genotype
on the roche amplitude they use one to
five different snips whereas if you use
um the auto genomics infinity it is just
based on one
um
smith that they call the magenta
and you can see that for a different uh
genotypes here you use different number
of smith they call them
the genotype depending on
the company here
so what that um part of the issue that
arises from there is that
um
when you use different platforms to try
to call for
the genotype you can actually get
some mistakes
for example
if you use
if you use um uh this slide here shows
that if you um
because the the dna array doesn't use uh
any probe to necessarily call for a wild
type if they don't see the signal then
uh they're not gonna call um uh
they're gonna call it as a long time
so for in this case uh when we look at
uh for example the first column the
second column for sip 2c19 star 17 is
actually a relatively newer
uh genotype that's been called so
the chip hasn't been incorporated to
call uh to use the snips to call the
star 17 genotype yet so when um in these
cases here when uh for example on
the cell line gm17203
it's supposed to be a star 2 star 17
genotype it'll call the star 2 because
it sees that it's built into the chip
but it won't call the star 17 because it
doesn't have a probe
to identify the star 17 snip so
um because it doesn't see a signal it
will automatically call a star one so so
on and so forth so um
so that is one of the the major
limitations of the dna available
so
because of that we saw that in our own
experiments and our own patient
samples that we have banked away we
started to see a number of discordant um
uh um
genotype pollen especially when we start
uh um comparing it to other platforms at
different places so
we
to one way around um
this is to
not use the dna range what if we use
sequencing um the advantage of using
sequencing is that the sequence of
humankind regions so we actually can
identify and see all the snips out there
and um
that are used to call a specific
genotype so the chances of me missing
uh or miss calling a um
a snip is uh is relatively low compared
to dna platform and also depending on
the way that you design
your uh your sequencing
say like there's a new mutation that has
been identified
after the sequence of the the patient
sample you already have the dna sequence
so you can actually as long as you have
that sequence data there you can go back
and actually like uh look at the old
patient samples and see whether they
have that mutation or not so you don't
need to necessarily resequence the
patient sample
so the next um
part of the presentation i'll go into um
what i've been doing for the past year
so in that we developed a custom panel
for pharmacogenomics on sequencing
so what really has made sequencing
possible now especially in the clinical
setting for clinical services is that
the price the cost of uh sequencing has
dropped it tremendously so you can see
in this slide here that um you know the
price of uh sequencing the cost of
sequencing has been trending down ever
since 2001 but it hasn't really dropped
back dramatically until 2007 or so so
between 2007 and 2012 you can see that
the price has dropped tremendously and
then recently in the past year or so the
price has
kind of leveled off
and the reason for the
the cause of the dropping deposits
because uh new technology has uh emerged
and that allowed us to uh sequence a
whole bunch of dna in one dna sequencing
so that kind of decreases the cost for
the
sequencing dna
so there are mainly two um competing uh
technologies out there right now for uh
next generation sequencing
and they both um uh use
have a similar goal
um so in order for next-generation
sequencing to work uh you want to
generate a whole bunch of clusters of
unique dna fragments
um the first uh section here on the
figure is um what a luminous system uses
uh what they have is that they have um
uh dna sequences that are normalized on
a solid surface so when you add your
genomic dna to it it will bind to these
probes and the way that it will bind is
that it will form a bridge
and um when you start doing a pcr
amplification there then the end result
is that you'll have individual clusters
of the same dna sequence on these
windows lights
how the aluminum system works is that
after you generate these clusters you
add specific dna nucleotides each one
having a different clause and label on
it so when our one specific
new proton is incorporated into your uh
into the
uh the sequencing reaction will generate
a different uh force in light and then
there are um imaging optics there that
will capture every single one so
depending on the type of fluorescent
signal that you'll see after each
addition
the machine is able to tell what dna
base was incorporated
the other competing major competing uh
next generation sequencing technology is
one that is based off of the
ion torrent and also the
um so again the goal here is to i have
um um
enrich for
um one dna sequence but instead of doing
it on clusters on a
solid surface what they do is they
immobilize um
each dna sequence on a beam
and how they achieve that is they have a
water emulsion where you have small
little water droplets inside this
solution of oil each one of these water
droplets contain a single beam and on
these beads actually have a dna sequence
that will bind to the
dna that you know the sequence so the
idea here is that you want to have one
dna sequence
in one b and one line
so when the pcr reaction happens inside
one of these water droplets um only one
dna sequence will be amplified and being
mobilized on
the uh
here
these beads and then are then added to a
whole bunch of small little uh wells and
a
sequencing reaction will happen
in each one of these rows so each one of
these wells will then have a different
dna sequence in it so that you can
sequence and determine the sequence
of each one of those wells for the
vehicle that's at the height
so um when you first want to design
a sequencing panel what are some of the
steps are involved here um so
um we're going to kind of go through
step by step what is the thought process
behind designing these kind of patterns
so the first thing that you want to do
is identify the regions of genes
um so once you identify
and know which areas that you want to
sequence there are mainly two different
routes that you can take you can look
what is commercially available or
um you can design your own kit um
so some of the advantages of um
using commercially available kits is
that um they tend to cover a wider
variety of different genes and they tend
to be a more general um
broad approach to
what we're looking for
um
the downside of using commercially
available kits is that
if you're looking for specific regions
some kids may or may not cover um that
region or
uh
or even the snips out that you're
interested in
um
and the other thing is that when you
start looking at some of these
emotionally available kits we might
require some additional proprietary
instrument in order for you to uh to use
it here
um
the advantages of designing your own kit
is that you can design a kit to cover
any region of interest yourself um but
then because of that
you also require some
expertise
because you need to
the designing of the panel and the
validation panel is up upon you to to do
yourself
after you know this um the next step is
to select some kind of target enrichment
strategy
um in our case for formical genomics
you're not um
you're not sequencing the original or
not sequencing the entire axon we're
actually just sequencing certain
sections of
regions of the gene so there are mainly
two different uh computing enrichment
strategies here the first one is a
multiplex pcr
so uh what is here is that you
uh
there are many many different prime
repairs that are
that will pcr amplify the regions of
interest so you would do this all in one
reaction to you um so the advantage of
this is that um there are very little
hands on time and it tends to be a
relatively quicker compared to the
second target capture mode
um the disadvantages of using a
multiplex pcr approach is that um
not all regions in uh of interest might
be um amplified uniformly and uh because
you have so many different time repairs
at one given time uh you might certainly
have some uh artifacts
the other uh uh
enrichment strategy that you can use is
what we call cap target capture so what
the company does is that once you submit
in your panel design is they'll design
probes that will hybridize and bind to
the regions of the sequence
uh the main um
advantage of using this kind of
technology is that you tend to get more
uniform coverage of the regions that you
want to sequence however the downside of
that is
uh it tends to be more labor intensive
compared to the multiplex pcr stream
um and then finally when you um proceed
on to the sequencing um
there are currently there are two main
competing platforms out there and
um some of the things that you want to
keep in mind when you're selecting uh
one sequencing platform over the other
are things like the quality of the
sequence of data um so what affects the
quality of the sequencing data is
the
sequencing accuracy of the machine and
the technology itself but also the
length of the of the sequencing needs
usually the longer the needs and more
easier it is
for you to align your sequence and data
afterwards
um the other thing that you wanted to
keep in mind too is the turnaround time
depending on the different types of uh
sequencing platform whether your uh turn
around time
can vary tremendously
and finally you also want to consider
the data analysis
so when you're designing a panel um you
first want to choose the regions of
interest and there are several different
ways that you can do that you can either
sequence the entire gene you can see
from just the exons um and the flanking
regions of the exons you can also
sequence just the x bonds themselves or
the atom regions and also the five prime
and three prime engineer
after you decide which regions you want
to sequence then you want to confirm
that
the
polymorphisms that you're interested in
are actually covered in these regions so
here i've listed another databases that
you can use to confirm that
then after you have confirmed this then
you can submit your regions of interest
to online software from the
different companies and then they would
um generate
the
design um either the pcr farmers or the
capture ports
sequence and then afterwards when the
design is done then they will um give
you some files that you can upload and
see how well the design works and you
can confirm that that using
some
genome browser make the
gene environment
so for in our case uh we wanted to
develop a panel that will look at the
pharmacogenomics of competitor
metabolism and also warframe
so this figure right here just kind of
shows you um all the different enzymes
and proteins are involved in the
metabolism of uh that's pretty good so
in our
panel here we actually
sequence all of the genes that are
present in this pathway
in warfarin um there uh this figure here
just shows the the number of different
proteins
and enzymes are involved with the
metabolism of the oil
and the
proteins and enzymes that are
boxed in blue those are the ones that we
targeted
so in summary we have about 19 different
genes that we were interested in and
this table just kind of summarizes there
and you can see that except for some of
these um
proteins they are uh common in both in
the metabolism
whereas in some they are specific for
one
so um after you decided which regions
that or genes that you want to sequence
um then you go online to any one of
these
companies that provide these custom
panel designs and you just enter in into
their software
so there are several different ways that
you can enter um the regions of interest
so this screenshot here shows that i
entered in the actual gene or the name
of the genome interested in sequencing
for those of us that are a little bit
more familiar with molecular biology and
genomics you can also enter in the
chromosome
region and location um
into the program and instead of just the
gene
so when your
panel is finished designing and
you'll get a report back and this is a
screenshot of
what the report will look like and
basically some of the data that you can
get from this is how big your
the number of regions that you're going
to end up
sequencing um the total amount of
the amount of genomic sequence that you
are going to get from uh one of these
targeted sequencing runs and more
importantly the amount of
area that is being covered from
uh the pattern so
when you proceed on to look into this
one further um not
not every single region that you want to
sequence
will be captured
um it's very rare that they'll get 100
coverage on every single gene that you
know and then you want to see things
um so in our case we decided that
anywhere um you know 97 and above is
considered acceptable so for our 19 gene
panel here and here are the results and
you can see that we get fairly big
coverage for most of the genes that we
are interested in so they range anywhere
from
91 to 100
so i mentioned before that you can also
get some files from these
design software where you can upload
onto the
ucsd genome browser and this is a
screenshot of the game
and you can see that there are mainly
three tracks there there are there's the
first track is the analyzable time so
this track right there um is
the region um that um that the panel
will capture for sure
and then the next track down you'll see
is what they call the non-copper trap so
these are the the regions that you want
to sequence but then the
technology uh enrichment technology that
you use they cannot amplify that region
enter that region
the third track is your region of
interest so these are actually the areas
that i'm interested in sequencing
and you can see that it will also align
to the gene that you're also going to be
more interested in
so we at the university of chicago
as our supporting platform and we
decided to use the target capture method
to
isolate the regions of interest and the
main reason why we decided to go with
the target capital was because it
provided a much more uniform coverage of
the regions of the union sequence
so when you are
talking to one of the sales reps from
either one of these companies you'll get
a diagram like this where they tell you
that they're you know these are
typically the time that it takes for
each step during the
procedure
um you know
that's i would i would take these uh
times with being assault because um you
know these are sometimes from actually
using the machine itself there are some
key steps that are emitted from this
workflow
um for example um they quoted the
library construction is two hours uh for
us we decided to use the target capture
so we use the haloplex um
technology and that actually takes about
nine hours for you to construct
the other
thing that we found that is very crucial
in our workup is that between um the
template preparation stuff in the
natural sequencing run um there's
actually a
temp quality control step that you want
to check your template before you
put onto the sequence sequencer and also
you need to enrich uh for the um
the sequences that you notice in the
sequence and this actually adds on the
additional algorithm so
you depending on
the type of sequencing platform that you
use and the type of um
uh technology that you use the overall
workflow and the time that it takes but
very tremendously
and the part that nobody kind of talks
about um when you're buying or deciding
on which gaming sequences
there's also the post sequencing data
analysis and um that will depend on you
know how complicated uh the complexity
of the of your career that you will
generate
and also the size of your gaming
depending on the
sequence
so um briefly i just want to go over uh
haloplex and
how does haloplex work um so what you do
in haloplex
is
that you take your
genomic dna and then you use eight
different pairs of restriction enzymes
to digest the dna
so what you do the end result of that is
for any one region in your dna we'll
have different um
uh fragments restriction enzyme
fragments that will be covered
and because of that uh of this you will
actually get much more uniform coverage
for a regional instance so after you do
the restriction enzyme digest then the
uh the company will provide you um
specific dna points that will bind to
the region of incense
so um the probe
has two components one is a sequence
quote that will bind to your region of
interest and then the other is a
piece of dna that it serves as a primary
binding sum or um
pcr amplification
so after you capture and isolate your um
your regions of interest then you add
the pcr primers are provided by the kit
and it will um amplify all of your
charcoal factory regions and actually
part of one of the pcr partners actually
has the molecular barcode so what a
molecular barcode is is it's a anywhere
from six to uh ten uh uh dna
unique dna uh
nucleotides that um will help identify
um
certain library preparations so what
this allows us to do is we're able to
multiplex and use and run multiple
patient samples with one sequence in one
because the molecular part of each
patient's happening is different
so and then at the very end of the pcr
reaction is in the middle you'll have um
the regenerative interest at your uh
that you want to sequence you'll have
them all up in the ballpark and at the
very end are the two regions where your
sequencing frame is going on
um when you purchase and design your own
haloplex
panel um as part of the kit you also get
a predicted uh
uh trace of the expected amplicon size
so for our panel right here we expect
our majority of the amplifiers to be
somewhere between 200 and 500 base pairs
um so when we actually did
our um
halo flex isolation from our genome
we're able to get our uh
amplifon to be within the specified
range so the majority of our amplifiers
do uh
are between 200 and 500 atmospheres
so the next step is the template
preparations
so previously i mentioned that there are
two different ways of amplifying the dna
on a solid phase support one is the
luminal wood we use a bridge base pcr on
the iron torque it actually uses the
motion based pcr
so again the key thing here is you have
little water droplets inside the oil
solution
and in each one of these water droplets
there is a
solid particle with a
dna sequence that your amphibon will or
your regeneration will hybridize too
so inside this water droplet when you
have one unique dna sequence per droplet
you will amplify
that sequence on the speed
so what you really want at the very end
when you're optimizing um you know
reaction is that you want one dna
template per bead um so you get a
majority of your beats are considered
monoclonal
now if you have more than one dna um
per bead what will happen is that you'll
have two different dna sequences
amplified on a single beam and this is
what we call polychromos and you want to
minimize that yes when you start
sequencing your dna that being
will generate information that will be
very hard to interpret
so as part of the quality control step
um
this uh what you want to do is you want
to see how many of your beads contain
the amplified
dna
so this is a kit that i'm trying to
provide where they have two different
probes that will bind to
the dna that is immobilized on the beam
and also uh the other uh dna of primary
sequence
after successful amplification
so if you have predominantly just um
the alexa uh
488 guy um signal that means that your
motion pressure did not work
now if you see both signals then uh uh
then that means that your
oil motion piece of
fairy
so um the caution here is that this um
step is um only as a recommended step in
the overall protocol for only
but i highly recommend that you do this
because it will save you a lot of
headache that way you don't need to put
before you even start sequencing your
dna you know that you're giving a
template preparation actually
um so the next step after that is a uh
template the enrichment step so
what you want to do uh the goal of this
step here is to maximize the uh and
isolate the the beads that actually have
dna from it you need to actually don't
know
so again uh this step here takes about
30 minutes
so finally we can get to the actual
sequence
so uh the way that the ion torque works
is that there are um on the actual
sequencing platform there are a number
of uh fabricated uh little wells that
are
present here and at the very bottom of
the well actually has a sensor that will
detect uh when the dna nucleotide is
incorporated in
now for the iron torrent there are
three different
sequencing chip sizes that you can use
and i've just highlighted them here um
so
the 314 uh what they call the 314 chip
is the
smallest chip that they have so whatever
by the smallest chip is you can see in
the middle of the chip there there's a
football shape um
part and the football shape is actually
the wells here it actually contains
so the 314 chip contains the least
amount of wheels versus the 318 check
which contains uh uh the most amount of
locks in the gym
so
based on the number of wells that are
covered in each chip and the uh
sequencing
that the
kit that you put on the sequencer you
can estimate the amount of sequencing
data that you would get so for your 3-4
chain chip
if you use the 200 base pair read link
sequencing kit you can estimate to get
around 20 megabases of data using the
314 chip about 200 megabases of data
using the 316 chip and anywhere from 0.5
to 1 gigabytes uh amount of data using
the 3d mutation
so how the iron torque really works is
um it is each one of those wells is
essentially a ph
um
so what happens in during a sequencing
reaction is that every time when a
nucleotide is is added on by the
polymerase uh proton will be ejected out
um
so because there um uh
a number of if you have a monoclonal um
b
all of the
given time it will be the same for all
the dna sequences
so you'll actually release a
large number of protons and
the um at the bottom of the well there's
actually a layer
that's built into the chip that can
detect the ph changes when the
nucleotide is incorporated in
so
uh how this equals any reaction actually
works is that uh if any one step
four different dna nucleotides are flown
into it so if one dna nucleotide is
incorporated into the dna sequence then
they generate a signal agent um you uh
inject out the proton and then
the valves can detect the changing ph
if the dna base is not incorporated in
then
you will not see a signal from that base
when you have actually two
uh bases that are exactly the same way
after another say that the tt
um what you'll actually see is that
you'll see an increase in the amount of
protons that are
incorporated in this room so this is a
very general way of how the intent works
so for our actual sequencing uh this is
the kind of report that you can expect
to get after completing a sequence again
so first of all um that the first thing
that you'll see is a heat map of the
chip itself so how you would read this
heat map is that the more red you see
that means that the more wells those are
the wells that actually have active dna
sequences that generated sequence
um so uh yellow is okay you don't want
to see blue blue means that it goes
so right next to that then you get some
metrics on how well the sequencing
reaction should go so
of the um
the wealth uh index um about 75 percent
of the wells were actually loaded with
beads
and uh of those beads all of the beads
actually have dna sequence on it
um
of all the beads um
95 of those beads were determined to
have uh were determined to be monoclonal
now only five percent of these will poly
clay
so again meaning 95 of the beads
actually only have one dna sequence in
here and five percent of the main leads
actually have more than one dna
so that's actually pretty good
and at the very end about 84 of these
were able to generate dna sequence that
we can use to uh analyze uh at the very
end
so uh the other thing that you will also
get is a distribution of the uh read
limit so for this particular sequencing
run uh the average uh read length was
about 102
so for um our sequence anyway here i'm
showing uh a four plex pcr uh four
clutch multiplex
well we have um two um
genomic dna isolated from the cell lines
and two patients here
and here are the uh post data and
sequencing analysis and this is the type
of information that you can get been
getting
so we can see that for um all four
samples here we've got an average rate
of uh weed length of about 150 base
pairs
the average uh uh
leave depth is about 70 somewhere
between between 65 and 75 so what we
need here is that for any one uh uh base
in the dna sequence that base has at
least 65 or 75 rings on
so um for each one of these samples we
were able to generate about uh 16 to 18
megabases of data and the amount of
analyzable regions in from this data is
about nine to ten negative indices
um so
based on our sequencing panel
uh depending on
what you define as um the cutoff of the
number of leads for your sample
you can see that we can uh range from um
80 coverage all the way up to
90 to 95 uh coverage
so you know for our initial try um this
is a uh fairly encouraging and we are
still currently optimizing um uh our
sequencing reaction to see if we can
get that in displays
so i previously mentioned that we were
currently
initially using the dna platform
and then we tried to uh use
it onto sequencing so we wanted to
compare the accuracy of our sequencing
panel to what we initially were using
uh in the dna
and you can see that for
our all of our
samples here so uh the corial cell lines
we have two different encore elsa
samples here we have 100 concordance
between
the data that we got from the sequencing
panel and from the data that we got from
our dna
and then the two patient samples that we
have one was for
um pivotal and one was from norfolk and
you can see that um for
when we compare the patient data from
our sequencing to the dna company we are
also
so that kind of shows us where we all
have right now so we're still in the
process of validating our um dna
handling right here um our dna
sequencing right now so um we're gonna
be uh chugging along with that and
this slide right here kind of uh
gives you on the website that i've used
in designing the panel so the smith
databases that i've used in um
uh for designing my fundamental genomics
panel um the next uh the middle part of
the slide here shows the custom panel
design websites that you can use so the
live technology ampliseq website that is
the one that is the multiplex pcr
technology that you want to use um the
agilent sure design is the one where you
use a target capture technology so
we used that one so i went to the sure
design
website so the screenshots that you saw
in the presentation are actually from
that website and finally here is the at
the very bottom here this is the
address for the ucsc
so
just to briefly conclude um
uh so pharmacogenomics is uh we're
starting to see at least at our
institution it's going to be used more
and more in clinical decision uh
making up some of the decisions um
because clinicians want to know uh what
drugs are effective for their patients
and if they can get that information
beforehand that's all about it
um currently even right now most of the
genotyping acids are used or either dna
or rape real-time pcr base
they're quick but i've highlighted some
of the limitations for each one of those
essays
um
because of those limitations it's very
important for a clinical lab to actually
validate each one of these assays before
they actually put into clinical use
and um finally
because of the reduction in cost and the
increase in the speed
that it takes to
uh to generate dna sequences um by dna
sequencing
it has been a much more viable
technology for the clinical
implementation of pharmacogenetic
geotable and what i've shown here is
that
you can actually design a custom
sequence in the house by the target
specific uh pathway target pathways in
the pharmaceuticals
so this concludes
my talk and i'll be happy to take any
questions um and here is a link for you
to
get your senior credits thank you